transport toujours et cette distance 1,6
km c'est ce que va à parcourir
prochainement une navette autonome en
test à saint quentin en yvelines dès
2021 l'itinéraire partira de la gare
située à montigny le bretonneux jusqu'à
la zone d'activités du pas du lac où se
situe plusieurs entreprises ce nouveau
moyen de déplacement circulera toutes
les 6 à 8 minutes en heure de pointe de
7h30 à 20h l expérimentation mise en
place par ile-de-france mobilité
l'agglomération démarrera au printemps
prochain et ce pour deux ans
reconductible interview collectées par
eléonore sinoquet c'est une navette
effectivement qui qui sera totalement
autonome et ce qui sera intéressant pour
nous c'est de voir comment cette
nouvelle technologie et comment ce
nouveau type de mobilité s'articule avec
les autres mobilité sur l'espace public
sur la voie publique voir comment elle
se comporte
on aura nos une doctorante qui suivra de
près 7
cette expérimentation notamment pour
avoir des remontées en termes de données
d'algorithmes toujours dans cette idée
de pouvoir progresser sur cette
technologie et voir si ça peut être une
tête ou une technologie père est né
viable pour un type de mobilité dans les
années à venir
et pendant la durée de l'expérimentation
ses trajets en navette autonome seront
gratuits